so 10 years ago I believe you visited
the cathouse on Kings
yeah the cathouse on the Kings yeah on
the Kings sorry and so how did this have
this wonderful sanctuary change your
life oh it was huge it was like we know
we talked about this and we had a feral
cat we've always had feral cats come to
our house because we have lots of cats
and a feral cat a wild cat will will
just sense that cat people lived there
and a feral cat obviously cannot be pet
or touched or anything they're they're
wild animals but we've done this over
the years and we fed feral cats so you
know I guess it's a little over 10 years
ago we were moving from our apartment
and just as we were about to move a
feral cat showed up and it was like feed
me and we were like yes of course we'll
feed you but we're moving and it we were
phased suddenly but this prospect of
like what are we gonna do this this
animal is like dependent upon us now but
we're moving it got to the point where I
was like literally driving across town
every day to leave food is this empty
house the cat was standing there was the
saddest things he's like where's my food
and I'm like I'm driving across John we
I can't keep this up I can't expect into
new tenants to take care of him or
whatever so I started looking into
rescues and looking into that whole
world and it's a you know I did again I
became educated was like wow there's
just there's just tons of kill shelters
if you bring an animal to a regular
shelter likely they will be killed
certainly a feral who can never be
adopted rarely what do you do with a
feral cat and so after a lot of research
I found this one place which I had never
heard of the cat house on the king´s
which was this one woman's massive
property up near Fresno that she had
turned in this ranch-style multi acre
property into this sanctuary an adoption
center where she had you know almost a
thousand animals that were totally cared
for it wasn't an I wasn't a hoarder it
was like an operation sure and she was
like yeah you know we actually have a
feral you know section and if you can
catch him you know you can bring him
here and I was like wow and where Oliver
everybody else was like we're full up
and they'll kill him and all this was
the one place I went to when I went up
there it was like one woman and a couple
of
maybe one other person and all of these
animals and I was like this was like the
definition to me of like a saint like
this was like this woman who had
dedicated her whole life to these
animals literally and was like making it
work she definitely needed help but and
I said to myself my god well what can I
do in exchange for this you know you
save this cat's life and these thousands
of other dogs and cats so I decided to
make this youtube video I said I'll come
back and I'll do a portrait of you and
the place a couple of minutes and you
know we'll put it on YouTube and this is
when YouTube was sort of new you know
and and it just we just as luck would
have it there were enough cat people out
there that it started to go viral and
people really saw that this was a this
beautiful soul that was doing something
so unique and she started to get
donations and it started to get more
well-known and now you know 10 13 years
later it's a it's a it's considered you
know it's a very well-known institution
you know around the world people come
from all over the world to visit this
place and support support it so it's a
big part of search-and-rescue story the
ending of the whole movie actually
happens at the cat house it actually
takes place at the cat house and I'm
trying to talk
Linnea Lattanzi oh the proprietor into
actually playing herself in the movie if
she'll agree to do it because he's such
a character
but yeah the whole movie actually
resolves at the cat house have you
thought about what would have happened
if you had moved one week earlier and
never met that yeah I know I hadn't
really thought of that it's been such a
you know my wife has said you know it's
the most important film you ever made
was that film for the cat house because
you know talking about direct action
that film because it went viral because
I made it because it exists and it
reached people that that institution
that sanctuary received much-needed
donations that saved a lot more animals
and so in terms of doing something
that's valuable truly valuable that a
little film you know when I think about
it you know is you know
definitely up there as being an
important movie of mine just because it
helped it ultimately helped a lot of
animals do you know how many views that
video has well I I think you know I
think now it's you know it's well over a
million views but it but it yeah you
know like but conversely you know like I
did this you know fun monster thing for
YouTube years ago deerforce five that
has 50 million views now oh wow okay but
the million and a half or whatever that
the cat house is way more valuable
because that that just means something
and we in real world terms you know
there are a lot of animals that got
saved because people gave because they
saw the video so yeah I'm I don't I
don't know what would it happened
certainly search-and-rescue wouldn't
have evolved the way it did because my
there's a there's a cat component and
there's a feral component and a rescue
component to the story that is that is a
threat in this crime story that is the
direct result of my experience with with
the cat house on the king´s and why I
feel it's appropriate to end the movie
there even though there's gangsters and
assassins and pornographers and all this
other stuff in the movie it ultimately
ends at the cat house you know which is
like the sweetest place on earth
you